my interest in Harlem is personal
political and professional as a child my
grandmother who lived on what was then
Lenox Avenue frequently took me to her
church to hear Adam Clayton Powell as a
young person hanging out in smalls
restaurant I met and talked with Malcolm
X the evening before he was assassinated
as an adult I lived in Harlem for 20
years and my formal research in Harlem
has as Professor Marvel pointed out
spanned more than two decades as you
know Harlem is a historic black
community that has often been a focus of
black activism against the racist state
major protest movements and charismatic
leaders as diverse as Marcus Garvey
communist city council member benjamin
davis and malcolm x have all found a
base there when i began my formal
research in this particular project in
1994 harlem had entered a period of
significant decline job losses were
reflected in an unofficial unemployment
rate twice that of New York City
simultaneous neglect by city and state
governments as reflected in cutbacks and
services as well as increased investment
in the private sector particularly in
high-end housing led to a period of
deterioration and decline between 1970
and 1990 the number of available housing
units in Harlem had declined by about
twenty seven percent this period of the
devastation and displacement in Harlem
was then followed by a wave of
gentrification and I'm sure you've heard
about this from some of your other
speakers these conditions were reflected
in health status infant mortality rates
in Harlem were twice that of new york
city as a whole this reflected national
epidemiological studies demen
strating that black women have
problematic birth outcomes in particular
higher rates of infant mortality and low
birth weight babies regardless of their
socio-economic position and that even
college-educated african-american women
have twice the infant mortality rate of
college-educated white women now in this
context the Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention circulated an RFP a
request for proposal and the New York
Urban League which was then based in
Harlem and was under the leadership of
now deputy mayor dennis walcott
submitted a research proposal to explore
the social context of reproductive
health in harlem no Lord's the CDC
wanted to know if race is not biological
then what is it that explains the
disparities and health outcomes for
African Americans of all socio-economic
classes now this question about racial
inequalities in health is particularly
important because the domain of health
disparities has become an arena for
asserting and contesting explanatory
paradigms about difference in equality
health and illness mainstream
interpretive frameworks in medicine and
health research have traditionally
attributed racial disparities in disease
to biological or genetic differences on
one hand or cultural and lifestyle
differences between racial groups on the
other notions of race that are based
upon a typological approach to human
variation other words the various types
of humans with the implication that
genetic differences related to race are
a major factor in explaining disease
disparities continue to pervade the
medical literature in fact this approach
has gained new life with the renewed
attention to genetics that is reflected
in the human genome project and the drug
industry's new initiative
to produce designer drugs for people of
different races anybody heard of idol ok
that's a designer drug produced by the
drug companies they hope to make a lot
of money for African Americans said to
work better on African Americans but
this is based on a rather old-fashioned
approach to race as opposed to ancestry
the cultural or lifestyle lifestyle
paradigms sometimes barely concealing
culture of poverty and deviance notions
are equally problematic allege cultural
traits behaviors or beliefs implicitly
or explicitly considered to be
associated with racial groups are often
seen as constant inch unchanging and
independent of social and historical
processes in other words Annie
centralized notion of culture is
substituted for race with little
attention to the structure of
constraints within which people make
lifestyle choices based on an
intersectional model incorporating the
oppressive structures of race class and
gender and the struggle against them the
Harlem birth white right research
project explored the meaning of
inequality in the everyday lives of
women in Harlem by investigating the
ways in which class race and gender
interact in specific situations to
condition health and to produce elevated
rates of illness and health we used a
variety of methodological approaches
participant observation was the center
of the research design we had teams of
ethnographies who spent two to three
months at each of 10 representative
neighborhood and workplace sites so that
for example we had I worked with with
another ethnography in a public hospital
one of my two of my graduate students
worked behind the counter in a fast food
restaurant that should ring that shall
remain
aimless other people hang out hung out
in neighborhoods we worked in a clerical
office on one hundred and twenty fifth
Street and we worked with vendors on one
hundred and twenty fifth Street when
there were vendors on 125th Street is
everybody familiar with participant
observation you know y you hang out and
you observe and participate in addition
we had twenty two women that we followed
over the course of a year or more we
held 11 focus groups and administered an
open-ended interview to a sample of
randomly selected women in Central
Harlem now one of the most important
strategies that we used was community
participation in other words trying to
involve the community and collaborate
with community residents in doing the
research we began by holding open
community meetings at various points
during the research process to discuss
the study to answer questions and to
solicit advice and when we held the
first meeting we got some very hard
questions such as why are you here such
as why is the centers for disease
control spending all this money on
research when you could spend it on
feeding people okay these were very
important and relevant questions which
we addressed and discuss with people the
project we formed a community advisory
board that met quarterly throughout the
project to advise the research team on
all aspects of the research and to
review findings in a subsequent research
project the research team incorporated
Photovoice and this is a participatory
action research strategy which was
developed by carolyn wine at the
university of michigan and what you do
in this kind of research is provide
community residents with disposable
cameras and you ask them to take
photographs around a certain topic and
then to write a text for the photograph
that they take and we did this with
respect to welfare
form and we got some very interesting
pictures and texts which were displayed
in City Hall for several months the
first task was to define Harlem how do
you define Harlem Harlem can be defined
in any number of different ways the
Harlem is a health district Harlem is a
community district the health district
has certain has different boundaries
slightly different boundaries than the
community district we defined Harlem as
a symbolic community and we defined
Harlem i'ts as people who work and live
in Harlem so we were interested then in
exploring the social conditions that
bear on higher rates of illness and
death and how community residents
struggle against them these were fully
reported in a book stress and resilience
the social context of reproduction in
Central Harlem and I understand you've
read or at least you've been assigned
the first three chapters which document
the stress or is connected with economic
decline and the displacement of people
from neighborhoods however we also
involved really heroic efforts to
address these issues and that's the
resistance and resilience part of the
title I use the term transformative work
to recognize that women work outside the
home inside the home but then also
engage in transformative work that I
define as efforts to sustain continuity
under transform circumstances and
strategies to transform circumstances in
order to maintain community continuity
transformative work involves many
domains for example households develop
flexible strategies for subsistence
including piecing together resources
garnered from state subsidies work in
formal informal and underground sectors
use of private food pantries and
charities private transfers and the
forms of services information and
resources from relative
and friends in other words where this
high unemployment people develop various
strategies to provide subsistence people
created work and some of you have
probably read Robin Kelly creating work
from play people created work form all
kinds of things they created work from
such activities as DJing flower
arrangement kitchen planning babysitting
hair care and vending all manner of
goods household strategies frequently
included education for one or more
members of the household often at a
public college facility such as where I
teach in the research we found that
among community residents there was a
tremendous nostalgia for community and a
determination to recreate it so
residents spoke very movingly of a past
which was characterized by a sense of
community the interview respondents
discussed many of the positive aspects
of the environment such as the variety
of cultural and spiritual activities
that may serve as protective factors for
them and mitigate some of the stresses
and strains perhaps you've been more
significant was the respondents view
that the cultural historical and social
advantages of living in a black
community outweighed a lot of the
problems to which the community was
subject 99% of the survey respondents
cited living in a black community as a
positive aspect of their environment and
I remember interviewing one particular
middle-class couple and this was before
Harlem was as gentrified as it is and
one of them pointed out that she had
been living on the Upper West Side in a
white area around the time that the
Central Park will be now called on the
central park five at that time they were
known as the Central Park joggers these
were five young men who were erroneously
arrested for
hacking a woman in in Central Park and
she said she used to go to work with
earphones on to kind of screen out all
the remarks of her co-workers turns out
of course these five young men were not
were not guilty of that crime and so she
then moved to Harlem because she said at
least I have a place to come home to
where I don't have to listen to that
despite the fact that they won't collect
garbage despite the fact that you can
keep up housing I don't have to deal
with this day-to-day racism so in
attempting to deal with problems around
housing and the environment women
utilize both individual and collective
strategies to obtain and retain adequate
shelter for themselves and their
families and to improve their housing
and neighborhood conditions these ranged
from individual daily actions to
organize struggles for more long-term
solutions one recourse women employed
was to take landlords to housing court
for neglecting repairs and almost forty
percent of the respondents to the survey
had been to housing court and over
two-thirds of those have represented
themselves against the lawyers of their
landlords others worked with block
associations tenant associations tenant
organizations and a wide range of
community groups individually and
collectively across social strata the
women we studied were very active
participants in efforts to improve the
quality of space in Harlem they did
things such as keep calling sanitation
to request the removal of garbage and
and to clean up vacant lots planting
flowers turning vacant lots into
community gardens or organizing against
environmental racism but all of these
interventions that I'm calling
transformative work it's important to
remember require considerable time and
energy and women are both working within
the household taking care of families
and also working outside the household
but then also doing this
work in their communities family and
support networks involving both men and
women played an important part in their
lives deindustrialization and the
consequent disproportionately high
levels of unemployment as well as the
expansion of the prison industrial
complex largely based on racial
discrimination in policing and
sentencing and selective enforcement of
laws has resulted in a shortage of men
as sons brothers fathers and partners
and an increase in women raising
children without support from men this
affects african-american women across
all social strata and in central harlem
at the time of the research
approximately two-thirds of all
households with children under 18 were
described as headed by women however the
researchers found that though economic
conditions severely strained support
systems people perceive family to be
important and were involved in a variety
of flexible support systems almost all
the respondents to the survey 95%
commented on the importance of family
ties and overall ninety percent of women
reported that family relationships were
most important to them despite popular
perceptions concerning the absence of
men we observed that women related to
men in a variety of roles and reported
that men in many different types of kin
and partner relations were important in
their lives despite the fact that they
were not formally married so the
research then revealed the fluid and
dynamic nature of family and support
networks the continuing importance of
blood related kin a wide variety and
great flexibility of residential
arrangements and the significance of non
blood kin and the importance of women
centered networks however it was the
women who were always responsible for
recruiting and servicing the support
network
and anthropologists have described this
kind of work as kin work and note that
unlike housework and childcare kin work
is generally unlabeled those of you who
are putting together dinners for example
for Thanksgiving this is kin work but no
one actually count skin work when you
talk about housework to talk about
childcare etc but kin work has a purpose
you're putting together support systems
because support systems are going to be
important and you have to service those
support systems and while our study
participants reported positive
experiences with family and support
systems they also reported constraints
among survey respondents the higher the
level of education the more frequently
family was reported as a major source of
stress and I think this is easily
explained by the heterogeneity of
african-american families the middle
stratum participants were frequently the
only member of their family to attain
middle-class status so of course people
everybody was calling on them for
everything and so while the support
networks are an important resistance
resource in conditions of inequality kin
work along with the other transformative
strategies women take on maybe
simultaneously stressful and protective
in researching resistance resources and
transformative strategies we came into
conflict with the Centers for Disease
Control national agencies and
institutions particularly those
concerned with health and disease often
have a strong investment in an
implicitly pathological model that
portrays communities as sick
disorganized etc and these people in
these agencies may interpret
oppositional behaviors as non-compliant
dysfunctional or pathological
furthermore these institutions are off
our frequently unwilling to accept
results of a study that point too long
terms structural change research that
emphasizes dysfunctional cultural and
individual behaviors produce
recommendations for what they call
manageable interventions in the lives of
their subjects on the other hand
research that is designed to illuminate
structural constraints and the ways in
which people resist them often point to
the need for large-scale social changes
such as improving access to employment
shelter education and healthcare and
national institutions are generally not
prepared to tackle these large-scale
social changes community residents
recognized that there were severe health
and social problems but also had a
strong investment in a health as
compared to a disease model of the
community the commitment to demonstrate
the strengths as well as the weaknesses
of the community was evident in a few
examples for example early in the study
the CDC requested data using traditional
categories found in public documents
unemployment percentage of people below
poverty percentage of people receiving
public assistance number of vacant
buildings etc so we put together a draft
of these statistics made little charts
made slides etc we showed them to the
Community Advisory Board and the
community advisory board said ok that's
fine but why don't you just reverse
that's statistics in other words why
don't you talk about the percentage of
people above poverty the percentage of
people who are employed the percentage
of people who are in school in other
words not change the numbers but think
about the way in which you represent a
community by stressing the negative
characteristics as opposed to stressing
the positive characteristics so as a
result of this discussion we created
additional presentation that didn't
change any figures but counterpose them
and that displayed the percentage of
people above the poverty line
people not on public assistance etc so
with the assistance of community
residents we tried to address the way in
which what appears as objective
statistical presentations emphasize
negative characteristics and thereby
legitimize stereotypes and unequal power
relations so together the research and
the community the researchers and the
community advisory board began to think
about alternative approaches to research
that would illuminate the resistance and
activism of women in trying to deal with
their daily lives so they talked to us
about researching such activities as
complaints of police brutality women who
call housing and try to get the housing
code requirements enforced taking leave
legal actions concerning job loss and
resisting the placement of children in
special education in other words
researchers generally don't look at
these aspects they look at the more
traditional things that paint the
community in a negative way and don't
show really what's going on with respect
to activism and resistance for example
it was a member of the community
advisory board who suggested that we
make housing court one of our research
sites that had not occurred to us
because housing court was not in Harlem
it's in downtown New York and he said to
us housing court is where so many women
from Harlem go to actually fight legally
to retain the housing and that was
absolutely true oh another example we
put together a brochure of on the
research methods of the study and we put
this together with the community
advisory board and the community
advisory board insisted on call on the
title exploring the strengths of the
community rather than something like why
is there hot wire they higher rates of
infant mortality and I brought a couple
of them
to look at which are somewhere over
there and you can maybe look at them
after class okay so once we completed
the research it was necessary to develop
a framework to address the question of
why african-american women and men have
higher rates of illness and death we
hope to speak not only to an academic or
public health audience about health
disparities but also to african-american
women themselves about their lived
experience we wanted to recognize and
name issues that are frequently
unlabeled and to bridge the gap between
critical medical anthropology which is
what this was and public health models
by demonstrating the ways in which
intersections of class race and gender
hierarchies are actually embodied find
our Express in the bodies of women in
order to incorporate and conceptualize
the effects of these hierarchies on
health as well as to integrate a history
of resistance and allow for the
exploration of agency we developed a
framework we termed the Sojourner
syndrome the Sojourner syndrome is
designed to express the intersecting and
overlapping gendered notions of
responsibilities found in the symbol of
Sojourner Truth in a speech that
underscores the memorable phrase ain't
IA woman Sojourner Truth dramatically
depicts the various responsibilities of
African American women carried out in
circumstances characterized by racial
and gender oppression she says quote
that man over there says that women need
to be helped into carriages and lifted
over ditches and to have the best place
everywhere nobody ever helps me into
carriages or over mud puddles or gives
me any best place on an ain't IA woman
look at me look at my arm I have plowed
and planted and gathered into barns and
no man could head me and ain't IA woman
I could work as hard and eat as much as
an
when I could get it and bear the lash as
well an ain't IA woman I have borne 13
children and seen most of them sold off
into slavery and when I cried out with
my mother's grief none but Jesus heard
me and ain't IA woman Sojourner Truth of
course was an born in slavery and was an
early abolitionists sojourner truth's
account embodies the findings of the
research the assumption of economic
household and community responsibilities
which are expressed in family headship
working outside the home and the
constant need to address community
empowerment often carried out in
circumstances made difficult by
discrimination and scarce resources in
addition the model of Sojourner Truth
speaks to the contradiction between the
ideal models of gender and the lives of
black women in other words exclusion
from the protect from the protections a
private patriarchy offered to white
women by the concept of womanhood
motherhood and femininity we suggested
to the Centers for Disease Control that
exploration of the consequences of these
intersecting responsibilities that exist
for african-american women across class
may give us insight into the way in
which class race and gender structure
constraints and choices and thereby
structure vulnerability to disease the
Sojourner syndrome expresses the
combined effects of race class and
gender elevated risk of disease is also
observed for college-educated women
because of this simultaneous exposure to
both racism and sexism and so we hope
then that this framework helps to
clarify the mechanism by which race
mediates both gender and class status
the consequences of race and gender of
being a black woman contribute to the
inequality of class status so we saw the
in the vulnerability of middle stratum
women in a study whose employment
situation was frequently precarious due
to restructuring or downsizing in the
public sector furthermore race can
dilute the protections of class again
middle-class black women may have
obtained attained the achievements
necessary for middle-class status but
they continue to suffer job and
occupational discrimination they are
less likely to have male partners and
more likely to become single heads of
households and for middle-class women in
the study who moved to a black community
to avoid racism their class advantage
was diluted by the structural
discrimination and neglect to which the
black community was subject so this
framework then also allowed us to
continue consider the interaction of
race class and gender discrimination on
one hand and agency and resistance on
the other the Sojourner syndrome which
speaks not only to the structural
complaint constraints that have
implications for illness but also to
what people do about them represents a
strategy for fostering the reproduction
and the continuity of the black
community in other words the Sojourner
syndrome is a survival strategy which
may have both short-term and long-term
benefits but it may also have costs and
among them may be serious health
consequences after completing the
research phase of the project
physiologists were able to identify
after we completed the research phase of
the project physiologists employed by
the cdc were able to identify the
physiological mechanisms by which
hormones released during episodes of
acute stress and chronic strain can
stimulate early labor which leads to
high infant mortality furthermore they
found that these alterations during
pregnancy also increased vulnerability
to maternal infections
stress can therefore cause the early
onset of labor as well as lowered
resistance to infections in other words
while race may not be biological racism
has biological consequences the
sojourner syndrome then attempts to
capture paradox that the enduring
duality of race lies in the complicated
fact that the imposition of race
inevitably creates the structural
context for producing oppositional sites
of resistance as well as creative spaces
for the articulation of subaltern
consciousness culture and opposition
race class and gender in Harlem thus
become potentially spaces for resistance
counter-narrative and the emergence of
Liberatore potential and I'm happy to
take your questions and comments
yes
yes actually my probably should have
brought slides but didn't get them
together in time this this was a
different project and this project was
called the New York State Scala
practitioner project and what we did
with this project is employed graduate
students I only teach graduate students
give graduate students fellowships to a
form a bridge between advocacy and
grassroots organizations and research so
they attempted to translate research and
make it usable to advocacy and
grassroots organizations and to also do
research themselves to make information
available so we gave people cameras and
they took pictures of different things
we ask them what has welfare reform
meant for your community and one picture
was of a chest of drawers and a mattress
which was out on the sidewalk and the
text said people are being evicted from
their homes and in the past people use
and this was in the 30s with the
unemployed councils people used to move
the things their furniture back in to
their apartments when they were evicted
but I can tell this this text went on to
say by looking in the drawers which were
full that this is not just sitting out
on the sidewalk people have been evicted
so there were pictures like that there
were also pictures of community gardens
and people saying this is the way life
should be it should be pretty we should
be able to have gardens we should be
able to have flowers etc so their range
of pictures with a range of different
texts yes
how you feel that the cyclical effect of
stressors being connected and related to
economic decline or displacement on as
far as black women and how like better
fix to their racing
well I think what has to happen oh are
you asking me what's happening in Harlem
now being gentrified or what is
necessary in the future yeah well what's
happening now i would say for low-income
women is probably increased stress
because as you know Harlem is being
gentrified you know some aspects of that
are good but many are very problematic
because people are no longer able to
afford to live there so after the first
study we went back maybe five years
later to look for some of the study
subjects and many of them had moved to
places like the Bronx or Brooklyn
because they could no longer afford to
live in Harlem so for middle income
women there may be a lower level of
stress because as Harlem gentrified you
get more services in Harlem such as you
know collection of garbage etc in the
long run well what we documented were
stressors that were related to
unemployment that were related to
working at very difficult jobs that were
related to having to fight the shelter
every moment and in the long run in
order I think to deal with those dresses
you're going to have to have major
structural changes that see for example
shelter as a human right or C healthcare
as a human right or see the right to a
job as a human right and I think at that
point then it's possible to talk about
oh what what disparities in health may
be related to ancestry but until one
deals with those issues I think it's
really irrelevant in many ways to talk
about racial differences yes
like I guess they're quite poor survive
like
no I would say it's not at odds with it
at all this study was designed to study
black women it we were not black men
were not a part of this study except as
they related to black women the
Sojourner syndrome does not suggest at
all that men are not involved in
assisting with the survival of the black
community in fact all of the research we
did really documents the participation
of men and kinship groups etc it is the
case however that with the prison
industrial complex this certainly fewer
men around that can participate in these
networks but our view was that the
Sojourner complex was named such because
we were dealing with women but this in
no way suggests in it suggests in any
sense that men are not involved in these
processes as well yes
that in different words like a strong
black box
and I'm not just in time
that women in general are socialized to
the to fulfill certain gender ideal
just like play with baby dolls we're
already socialized to be mothers you
know
a curious do you believe that that life
can end this
ocean rises and young age to
yeah I I think I hear what you're saying
one of the things that the centers for
disease control was concerned with is
the fact that black women across class
had higher rates of infant mortality low
birth weight babies and infant mortality
than white women and so the question
they asked is if this occurs across
class and you say as an anthropologist
there's no such thing as race than what
is it so what we attempted to do was to
really demonstrate what are the issues
that affect black women across class and
they and certainly they affect them in
different ways in different
socio-economic strata having documented
all of that um the conclusion is not I
think that black women should not do
these things but I think it's important
that women be conscious of what they're
doing and so very often when I've spoken
to black women especially middle stratum
black women it resonates with them
because they are not conscious of the
fact for example that they're doing kin
work that they're holding together
networks that they're doing things on so
many different levels because they just
do it automatically I think it's
important to be conscious of it and to
work in such a way that deals with the
causes of ill health as part of the
social structure rather than as
individual failings so when people see
well it's not me it's really a whole
structure of things out there and this
is a common problem among black women I
think the the way in which people
address that then is very different
rather than address it individually you
may want to address it collectively I
think that's it okay
alright then dr. Mullins for a great
presentation